l'Ukraine n'est ni absolument ces
accusations et inviter la IEA à venir
inspecter des sites en Ukraine pour
montrer que il y a absolument aucune
intention de faire une pomme sale ici en
Ukraine et sinon l'Ukraine avait aussi
demandé au Royaume-Uni et aux États-Unis
qui sont les consignateurs du même
random de Budapest contre l'Ukraine
avait renoncé à l'arme nucléaire c'est
de pays avec la Russie avait signé ce
même rorandum avec une des formes de
garantie de sécurité qui n'en sont pas
vraiment des garanties mais ils ont un
point qui est que le Conseil de sécurité
des Nations unies doit être saisie en
cas de menace d'utilisation de l'arme
nucléaire contre l'Ukraine l'Ukraine
estime que c'est le cas en ce moment et
on appelait donc à une discussion
elle-même au sein du Conseil de sécurité
de l'ONU mais l'Ukraine dénonce aussi un
Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU qui est
dysfonctionnelle de la vie de Kiev
puisque la Russie y a encore le droit de
veto et donc bien sûr aucun aucune
action contre la Russie pour condamner
les actions de la Russie en Ukraine
n'est possible tant que la Russie
disposera encore de ses droits de veto
l'Ukraine appelle à la communauté
internationale de chercher des solutions
peut-être en remettant en question le
fait que la Russie avait automatiquement
hérité du siège tenu par l'URSS au sein
du Conseil de sécurité en 1991